let's go quickly to Baghdad trade
yangste is standing by live what do you
know what are you here on the ground
Brett good evening we are still
gathering information about this attack
in western Iraq towards a military base
that houses US troops the important
thing to remember here is all of the
reports and according to Iranian state
television
these are ballistic missiles
surface-to-surface missiles that have
been fired this is a major escalation if
confirmed these types of missiles simply
due to the fact that what we've seen in
the past is mortars and rockets being
fired towards American and Iraqi bases
mostly run by the Iraqis but housing the
Americans so again if this is confirmed
tonight the number that we've been able
to get from officials and jennifer
griffin reporting over at the pentagon a
major escalation and something that
people in baghdad have been concerned
about we spoke with residents here today
and as we reported earlier on special
report they are extremely concerned
about what is to come there was a sort
of calm before the storm feeling in
Baghdad today because many people here
have experienced this before knowing how
quickly conflict can erupt in the region
and this was the major concern that if
Iran does launch a major counter-attack
in as a result of the Americans taking
out their top military commander Qasem
Soleimani
outside of Baghdad International Airport
last week that this could evolve into a
much larger conflict we were looking at
a proxy war in the region mostly they're
small attacks on Iraqi bases that house
of American troops more than a dozen of
them over the past six months
but again ballistic missiles are a
completely different thing dealing with
in the region and coming from Iranian
territory this leaves all options on the
table for the Trump administration we
are getting a statement from a White
House I'm not sure if you guys have it
yet
from Stephanie Grisham the press
secretary indicating that the president
is aware of the situation and has been
briefed in his consulting with his
national security team look for more
response from the White House throughout
the evening because that is the big
question now the president has promised
that he will respond strongly he made
many of those comments online and in
person
we will see what the response from the
Americans will be as a result of this
report of Iranian attack Brett rains
live in Baghdad Trey thank you